[Music]
[Laughter]
submitted by I'm talking about the
freaky girl I'm talking about when we
didn't cast you we casted a better model
just kidding I don't know you then no
probably not
why I love you arica no Alice here
towards the end of Uncas the last uncle
I saw was a the summer summer vacation
summer break one oh yeah when you and
your friend Vicky was like no that was
an uncle that was Asian bad Wow okay oh
yeah then I wasn't here during uncle you
see that's why that's why yeah
yes it's in nobody here our turn you
probably never knew about laughter Oh
for real ten weird ones is one of them
an aerobic exercise like it's an
exercise to left laughing is an aerobic
exercise like jogging I don't care what
the hell I do that laughing ages you
more what no that's why that lady had no
expression she's like I don't want to
get old so then every picture she's like
there's no girl like that it's a
catch-22 though because you don't want
to laugh because you don't want to look
old right cuz you're gonna get old but
then if you don't laugh that means that
you're not happy inside so then you're
gonna be old and your body's all [ __ ]
up what what if what if you are happy
inside you just don't get the wrinkles
oh god that's so scary you just changed
the way you laugh you're just like it's
like holding in a sneeze like you still
get it out but then if you it doesn't
feel that satisfying as a achoo I know
but you don't get the recoil so you get
the benefit no I've been getting some
deep bass wrinkles right hearing because
I laugh so much since I've been with you
guys that means you had a great life and
I'm like I'm proud of these wrinkles I
love my laugh Ringgold I don't care I
like how you're using the wrinkles
getting the wrinkles as hanging out with
JK yeah cuz I laugh but it's not because
of just we're getting older no it's
because I know I'm 27 I don't think I
don't think I'm that old so she's
getting wrinkles okay there's a girl but
I know who she never smiles in pictures
shows goes like the Kim Kardashian cry
did you go like because she's not trying
to make Rita's oh oh this is so much
Botox she can once in my eyebrows and
see what was light and you can't frown
so now I was doing a photo shoot they
like give me like an angry look and I'm
like yeah and that's what that point I'm
like I'm never getting Botox again
because now I keep growing again control
your muscles move yeah so there's this
neuroscientist and part-time stand-up
comic no [ __ ] awesome neuroscience
part-time stand-up comic okay that's
cool my name is Professor Sophie Scott
and so she's revealing the ten things
you probably didn't know about left her
so her number one is that rats are
actually ticklish I've seen that video
it's so cute how are your rats they're
all right they're slowly dying it's kind
of I saw the house that you built for
them Dan's like bawling little jealousy
to actually have all these toys and [ __ ]
like they live better than me she took
like those old cardboard boxes from like
those the Box chips yeah she cuts him up
into little tunnels and stuff him to
call them
and there's someone cared about me like
that I saw my rat dead on the bowl of
food you what I found my rat dead on the
Honorable like this you're very strange
like what yeah and her favorite was
sunflowers like you know in the little
thing like she always eats the sunflower
seeds first and then she just leaves the
pellets pick ass [ __ ] so she died with
the sunshine with like honor bowl of
food like this she died doing what she
loved yeah good just more she was
protecting her food while she was dying
yeah I want this yes the second point
here is laughter isn't about jokes so
most people when you ask when you ask
him like what makes you laugh people
will say jokes or humor but apparently
there's the psychologist from the
University of Maryland found that people
it's truth no people are most likely to
laugh when they're around other people
so it's like more of a form of
communication rather than laughing
because of a joke I laughed by myself
sometimes in the bathroom what
everything he's had this trend recently
where he farts and then I try not to say
anything or get this cuz it's just
horrible
so it's quiet and then he starts
cracking up like he starts [ __ ]
having a ball like you're [ __ ] weird
because I feel like it's almost like uh
you know those scenes were like imagine
you going camping right and you're the
only one in the mountains and it's
wilderness so you're just there and
you're just like so it's like such an
epic scene so we'll be sleeping and it's
dead quiet you don't hear [ __ ] and it's
just and it just kind of ruins the
entire like serenity of it I just feel
like it's so funny so I start laughing
I'm like [ __ ] in the bed shaking oh
you're just the epitome of happiness I
love it number three your brain can tell
the difference between deliberate and
helpless laughter what what's always
love yeah I'm never gonna really go and
people get scared or nervous they start
laughing no so apparently there's this
part of your brain that as soon as you
hear laughter that part of your brain is
activated and that part of your brain is
the part that controls the muscles in
your face so like immediately without
even finding it funny your brain all it
automatically wants to laugh because
laughter is contagious Oh like like when
we get laugh attacks
here like remember last time when the
teacup ride I thought it was his friend
and it was his girlfriend and I thought
I saw a buff man but it was just a woman
that was buff yeah because it was a
genuine mistake so that was the Nels the
helpless laughter because I didn't want
to laugh all right and then it was
contagious because every time I stop
laughing I hear his giggly ass that made
me laugh and he just kept going back and
forth those are fun yeah that was
actually my bed that's point number four
the contagious laughter but actually
point number three what it actually here
is sorry guys is that that your brain
can automatically tell the difference
between stage laughter or genuine
laughter that's how those sitcoms don't
affect us like you know when you watch
like Full House or something in a
lecture track you don't feel compelled
to start laughing with them you're just
like oh they thought it was funny so I
already told you point number four what
you left her is contagious
it is especially Casey's laughter I
don't know what the joke was I can hear
him like 10 miles away right that's
[ __ ] funny and laugh Casey's laughter
brings such joy
he's like a dolphin petting sucking love
it used to be really self-conscious
every why it's such a blessing on the
world so point number five is people you
know are funnier
so apparently laughter encourages
laughter so that's why I add a comedy
club they always have people warming up
the audience oh yeah because then like
you're already used to laughing but
apparently if you hear a joke and that
person tells you that that joke was by a
famous comic you're gonna find it way
more funnier than if that joke was being
told by a nobody hmm why maybe your
brains primed for it right
wait number six interesting laughter
doesn't make you fit her so you know how
you were saying okay always saying it'd
be cool if no I said I thought that's
what I was taught in fifth grade oh
really oh you thought laughing is
supposed to burn calories apparently mr.
Gomez has been lying to me
no so it does burn calories Oh if not
more calories than if you would go
running so that's like the way yeah yeah
yeah so you can't go to like the Laugh
Factory for 30 minutes and say oh I did
my cardio today yeah so apparently you
can burn an extra ten to 40 calories for
every 10 to 15 minutes that you left
that's a long that's really long yeah
I'd be a machine gun laughter you just
save 10 or 15 minutes laughing maybe
when you're high and then you laugh for
a long time when you're high you laugh
it feels like two hours but it's
probably like 30 seconds point number
seven relationships last longer when you
laugh big sister can you are you
listening to this cuz every time I'm
around you I'm not laughing you're
depressing it's book I met someone like
that there's there's this one guy that I
knew where like where we can be sitting
around was one time we were talking
about puppies I'm like [ __ ] all
puppies my parents never let me have a
puppy because they said it would die
damn Debbie the downer
look do it and we just stopped inviting
him out because everything like oh I
[ __ ] love eating at this place when I
was little I got rapport I'm like you
know let me get the [ __ ] out we just
talked about the car [ __ ] worse yeah so
there's this study that they were so
couples that laugh and smile together
they end up feeling better immediately
after a fight oh yeah they're able to
last longer in the relationship and try
to the other the other couples that so
dumb [ __ ] I can't even imagine what you
two would fight about a lot I don't like
his fourth day everything anything and
everything all the time so we'll fight
but then what's cool is we'll be yelling
at each other and then one of us always
says something really stupid we call
each other we start laughing after but
then we also pretend like we didn't make
up yet how cute talking about we're like
you guys already obviously both you guys
are laughing so obviously
are mad at each other anymore but you
still have your Eagle okay let's say
sorry
I like that cuz I imagine two just two
bears growling of each other I didn't
know how many problems I had until I met
her
really psychological that's what we're
here for
I know I want that to really happen
isn't actually speaking to each other
can you wear this bear oh my god with
the baby's born yeah yeah this is your
argument box every time you guys get
into an argument you stupid [ __ ] I want
that forever boy number eight
laughter requires precise timing so in
conversations people will laugh towards
the end of a sentence or like with
comics like comedians they have to they
have to be really sensitive with the
timing that time means everything yeah
like when to give a pause for people to
react to the jokes they also have to
come balance back if no one actually
reacts unless you guys are really close
then you can just start with three words
and then that's it you already know
where they're going you're like I love
Luisa K first timing I [ __ ] love him
so much
Lucy K's awesome I love him yeah point
number nine laughter is attractive so
apparently strangers find it more
attractive if you laugh at their jokes
oh not at them okay that's okay cool the
last point here is that some things are
almost guaranteed to make you laugh for
example if you hear someone that's
trying like that just can't contain
their giggles when they know
they shouldn't be laughing like this job
immediately that's the best yeah I love
seeing that on uh on uh what is it set
no it's a certain Matthew Versailles
night but I guess Saturday night is live
yeah and when they can't contain it it's
just [ __ ] hilarious
I've done job interviews where we met
some odd characters that started making
us giggle look at Michael and Michael's
like holding in as laugh I love that
face and it has like a [ __ ] piece of
paper and you shaking like holy [ __ ] and
we're sitting there [ __ ] cracking up
at the guy and they have no idea we're
cracking up out of our face that people
do when they're trying not to laugh it
yeah that one I [ __ ] love that face
hope you guys enjoyed that video if you
did a really cool way to communicate
that to us and for you to never miss
another video is by subscribing so click
on that little subscribe button and
you'll never miss an episode for the
next episode click right up here